what I want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about seismic waves size
Micke waves one because they're
interesting by themselves but they're
also really useful for figuring out what
the actual composition of the earth is
you've seen my video on the actual
layers of the earth and seismic waves
are crucial to actually realizing how
people figure it out what the different
of layers of the earth are and just to
be clear seismic waves they're normally
associated with earthquakes but they're
any waves that travel through that
travel through the earth that could be
due to an earthquake could be due to an
earthquake earthquake or just really any
kind of large explosion an explosion or
anything that really essentially starts
sending energy through the rock on earth
or really through through earth itself
now there's two fundamentally different
types of seismic waves and we're going
to focus on one more than the other one
is surface waves one is surface waves
and the other is body waves
body waves now surface waves are ones
that literally travel across the surface
of something in this case we're talking
about the surface of the ground and this
right here is a depiction of surface
waves and these really are more
analogous to the type of waves we
normally associate with the surface of
water and there's two types of surface
waves Rallye waves and love waves we
won't go into a lot of details but you
can see that rrally waves are kind of
the ground moving up and down right here
the ground is moving up here it's moving
down here it's moving up here it's
moving down so you can kind of view it
as kind of a ground roll the love waves
are the essentially the ground shifting
left and right so here it's not moving
up and down but here it's moving if
you're if you're going if you're facing
the direction of the wave movement it's
moving to the left here here it's moving
to the right here it's moving to the
left here it's moving to the right in
both cases the movement of the surface
wave is perpendicular to the direction
of motion so that we've got sometimes
called these transverse waves and these
are essentially analogous to as I said
kind of what we see in water waves now
the more interesting thing are the body
waves because the body waves first of
all they're the fastest moving waves and
these are also the waves that are used
to figure out the structure of
the earth so the body waves come in two
varieties you have your P waves or
primary waves you have your P waves and
you have your S waves or secondary or
secondary waves and they're depicted
right over here and these are these are
actually this is actually energy that's
being transferred through a body so it's
not just moving along the surface of one
and so here in this diagram that I got
from Wikipedia which I think Wikipedia
got from the US Geological Survey we
have a hammer being hit on some rock or
whatever and what you see is right when
the hammer gets hit at this end of the
rock and I can zoom in a little bit so
let's say I have this rock over here and
I hit and I hit it right over here with
a hammer or something what that what
that's immediately going to do is it's
going to compress the rock that the
hammer comes in touch with it's going to
compress that rock but then that energy
essentially the molecules that the
molecules are going to bump into the
adjacent molecules and then those
adjacent molecules are then going to
bump into the molecules right next to it
and then they're going to bump into the
molecules right next to it so you're
going to have this kind of compressed
part of rock moving through the wave so
these are compressed and those molecules
are going to bump into the adjacent
molecule so kind of immediately after
that the rock will be denser right over
here the first things that we're bumped
those will essentially bump into the
ones right above them and then they will
kind of move back to where they were and
so now the compression will have moved
and if you fast forward it will moved a
little bit forward so you essentially
have this compression wave if you hit
the hammer here and you essentially have
a changing density that is moving that
is moving in the same direction of the
wave in this situation in this situation
that is that is the direction of the
wave and you see that the molecules are
kind of going back and forth along that
same axis they're going along the same
direction as the wave so those are P
waves and P waves P waves can travel
through air that's what essentially
sound waves our compression waves they
can travel through liquid they can
travel through liquid and they can
obviously travel through solids and
depending and
they'll travel the slowest will
essentially move at the speed of sound
330 meters per second which isn't really
slow by everyday human standards in a
liquid they'll move about 1500 meters
per second and then in Granite which is
most of the the kind of crustal material
of the earth they'll move it around
5,000 meters per second let me write
that down
so 5,000 meters per second or
essentially 5 kilometers per second if
they're moving through a granite now S
waves
S waves are essentially if you were to
hit a hammer on the side of this rock so
let me draw another let me draw another
diagram since this is pretty small if
you were to hit a hammer right over here
what it would do is it would temporarily
kind of push all the rock over here
would deform it a little bit and that
would pull a little bit of the rock back
with it and then this rock that's right
above it would slowly be pulled down
while this rock that was initially hit
will be moved back up so you fast
forward maybe a millisecond and now the
next layer of rock right above that
maybe I should draw it actually let me
draw it like this the next layer of rock
right above that will be kind of
deformed will be kind of deformed to the
right and if you keep fast-forwarding it
the deformation will move upwards and
notice over here once again the movement
of the wave the movement of the wave is
upwards but now the movement of the
material is not going along the same
axis that we saw with the P waves or the
compression waves it's now moving
perpendicular it's not moving along a
perpendicular axis or you can call this
a transverse wave the movement of the
particles is now on a perpendicular axis
to the actual movement of the waves and
so that's what an S wave is and they
move a little bit slower than the P wave
so if an earthquake that were to happen
you would see the P waves first and then
at about 60% of the speed of the P waves
you would see the S waves now the most
important thing to think about
especially from the point of view of
figuring out the composition of the
earth is that the S waves S waves can
only only travel through solid only
travel through solid and you might say
wait I've seen transverse waves on water
that look like this but remember that is
a surface wave we
you're talking about body waves we're
talking about things that are actually
going through the body of water and a
one way to think about this is if I had
if I had some water over here so let's
say that this is a pool I'll draw a
cross-section of water if I draw a
cross-section of water I could have
drawn it better than that
let me if I have a cross-section of
water right over here let's think about
it and hopefully it'll make intuitive
sense to you if I were to compress some
of the water if I were to kind of slam
some part of the water here with like a
big I don't know some type of I were to
just compress it really fast it would do
the p-wave could transmit because those
water molecules would bump into the
water molecules next to it which would
bump into the water cules next to that
and so you would have a compression wave
or a pea wave moving in the direction of
my bump so P waves it makes sense and
the same thing is true with air or sound
waves that it makes sense that it could
travel through a liquid but let's say
that you let's say that if I remember
were under the water we're not thinking
about the surface we're thinking about
moving through the body of the water
let's say that you were to kind of let's
say that you were to kind of take that
hammer if you were to take a hammer and
kind of slap the side of this little
volume of water here well essentially
all that would do it would send a
compression wave it would sent a
compression wave in that direction it
really wouldn't do anything it wouldn't
it wouldn't allow a transverse wave to
go that way because it's not going to
the the the water doesn't allow it to
kind of it doesn't have this elastic
property where something bounces that
way it's going to immediately bounce
back that way it's not being pulled back
like a solid wood so S waves only only
travel through solids so we're going to
use essentially our understanding of P
waves which travel through air liquid or
solid and our understanding of s ways to
essentially figure out to essentially
figure out what the composition of earth
is